students at desert oasis high school in
the southwest valley really concerned
for their safety now their parents want
to see some change so all this comes
after a handful of incidents over the
last couple of weeks victoria saha is
live tonight with the message parents
and students want the school district to
hear victoria
two big questions here tonight when will
the violence stop at desert oasis and
when will the school board step in to
help stop that violence one parent
actually hosted her own meeting tonight
helping parents to be vocal about
holding school leaders accountable when
it comes to keeping their children safe
at schools
at this point school doesn't feel like a
safe place that he should a comment
heartbreaking to hear from any student
every time that intercom goes off i
don't know if it's just me or anybody
else it sends me to like a little
anxiety attack this is the constant
worry for students like christian
melhausen a junior at desert oasis
earlier this month there was a gun
reported on campus then the next day a
fight broke out in the common area
prompting the lockdowns then just this
past friday a student was arrested after
a gun was found on campus there has to
be a way so that our kids can go to
school and feel safe which is why parent
sheriff morgan is taking matters into
her own hands she heard from the school
staff but felt they did not help address
the issues at bay and thinks more can be
done basically working with the student
to figure out why they did what they did
and how do we prevent them from doing it
further another parent who wanted to
remain anonymous tells us she
volunteered to be a monitor back in
december at desert oasis she gives us a
summary of what she saw there was no
admin walking around nobody was telling
anybody to go to class except for me
morgan says she has reached out to every
school board member to add school safety
as an agenda item for thursday night's
school board meeting but has not heard
back from them
i did bring this topic up with school
board president irene cepeda she did
tell me she was willing to speak with me
this afternoon but she has not returned
to any of my calls victoria live local
now